Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
What's going on guys. This is Rob and, uh, I don't know.
No, if we ever really covered this, I mean, I guess we kind of did,
but if we did do it, that it was back in the day when my video sucked.
And so if we did cover it, we're going to remaster it,
but we're basically doing the crooked world story.
And the reason why we're doing this is because of what's going on with X of
swords and the return of Jim Jasper's, right. There's been a lot of talk,
especially in my videos about how powerful Jim Jasper's is about what he's
capable of and how dangerous of a character that he is. But in reality,
I don't really think a lot of people are fully aware of what Jim Jasper's can do
and what makes him so powerful and really so dangerous.
And this story really covers it. Now,
the other part of why we're doing this is because this also covers the nature of
Saturday, right?
The role she plays and which was really kind of first introduced in the Marvel
comics. Now, a couple of things to understand here, this story,
the crooked world is,
was technically kind of collected into a more recent seven issue story.
When I say recent, I mean, back in the mid nineties. Um,
but this story was really first launched when Marvel was creating what was
called Marvel UK and Marvel UK was quite literally Marvel comics attempt to
expand into the United Kingdom.
And of course they did it by creating captain Britain.
The result of this is that you had Alan Moore and Alan Davis who essentially put
this story together.
And so one part of this is kind of a reworking of the history of, uh,
of captain Britain in terms of rolling.
You're more in line with the main Marvel comics universe itself.
And then the other part is everything going on in the crooked world.
So we're only going to really cover the second part here. Uh,
we're going to kind of skim over a lot of this stuff, like the reworking of his,
of his story and his powers and things like that,
because that's not overly important here. What, I mean,
what you know about captain Britain right now in terms of reading extra swords
is all that really matters when it comes to his character.
And Jim Jasper's is really the main focus here, right? So, uh,
this initially picks up with both Brian Bradick, captain Britain,
as well as a character named Jack doff. Now,
Jack doll was initially introduced to the old captain Britain stories as
essentially a sidekick, right? Because this was written back in the 1980s.
And this was still a time in comic books where sidekicks were still a relatively
prominent thing.
The reality is the sidekicks are kind of been going the wayside, uh,
ever since the 1960s, right?
But it took about 20 years for us to see sidekicks and a lot of ways beginning
to go away. A lot of that was because of Batman because the Robin character,
the Robin archetype was still exceedingly popular and it really has been, um,
it's one of those things where I think publishers outside of DC kind of failed
to understand that the popularity of Robin was because he was effectively a
legacy character,
not every sidekick that was out there was popular or needed to be there.
And so Jack doll was actually one of these characters that was kind of being
phased out at the time. This story was being written.
The other part of this is that in the early captain Britain stories,
he was given a Sceptre that kind of allowed him to channel and use his powers.
This too is something that was being removed.
And that's the reason why when he sent on this mission to this alternate reality
in earth, two 38, but not really given any indication of what the mission is,
once he passes through that dimensional barrier,
his costume changes and he loses a Sceptre right.
This was kind of a really on the nose. Like this is the new captain now.
But the idea here is that once you sit into this location,
he immediately stumbles upon what is in effect, a bank heist, right? Like this,
this robbery going wrong.
Now this robbery is being held by a group called the crazy gang or being
orchestrated by a group called the crazy gang.
And captain Britain does what he does. Right.
He kind of beats them up a little bit and says, Hey, you know,
you guys need to stop all that kind of stuff, but while all that's going on,
Jim Jasper's is watching it happen.
And it's really because of the crazy gang kind of seems to be operating at the
behest of Jim Jasper's, right.
They're basically kiss henchmen and they're kind of carrying out his plot,
but the whole purpose behind this is really just more for fun and games that
what you have is you have Jim Jasper's who created the execution or who has the
execution are here and he's also got the queen of hearts, right?
So you guys kinda notice it's very similar to Alison Wonderland in terms of how
this goes on. And the result of this is that when he asked the queen,
what should we do? Her response is off with his head, right?
And that's when the executioner comes along and then it leaves captain Britain
taking the fight outside. Now, again,
Jim Jaspers is kind of watching all this unfold, right?
He's watching all this take place and it's kind of entertained by it, right?
Like this is kind of interesting, right?
I'm kind of intrigued by everything I'm seeing. He does of course,
want to see cabinet Britain defeated, but he is kind of intrigued here.
Now with this fight, basically getting to the outdoors and essentially,
you know, the forces of the crazy game being defeated, Jim Jasper is,
gets into his flying teapot and then basically takes off, right.
He just ends up escaping with the crazy gang and then that's basically it.
Right? And so, you know, the Dormouse is the one flying it.
So you can tell right off the bat, things were a little wonky here.
Where's captain Britain kind of looks around and is like,
none of this really makes sense. Like this is kind of wild.
I don't really understand this. And he ends up finding a poster on a wall.
This is kind of reelect the British national party light,
which is starkly different from what we see in the main Marvel universe. Well,
the British national party doesn't really exist. It's like a major figurehead,
right? They're not ruling anything. And so what you end up getting is,
is really, uh,
Jack doll and captain Britain kind of going through and checking out and
investigating a few things inside of, uh, inside of London itself, right?
To figure out the differences between the universe they're from,
and this place that they're in. Now,
this is when we kind of skim over stuff and sort of throw in a few little
highlights here and there. But for, for most everything else,
we can kind of blow it off.
But one of the big takeaways that comes out of all this is that everything
really is just starkly different,
but everything really is just starkly different.
And they don't really understand why,
why they're not really able to fully grasp why things are so intriguing here.
What you also have are three major things that take place.
The first is these various, you know,
homeless people who are out there that are drinking this alcohol and Jack doll
ends up drinking a little bit of it as well.
And it's almost like they have this kind of mental awakening of how things truly
are not for the most part because they're homeless.
And because of the outcasts of society, nobody takes them seriously.
And they consider the ramblings about how things have here versus how things
really are to really just be some kind of psychosis or a drunken stupor or
something like that.
But the second thing that happens is there's this giant heap of machinery that
actually just kind of became sensitive more or less and is walking around and
causing all kinds of chaos. Now,
captain Britain responds and ends up basically kind of defeating this thing,
but also drawing the attention of the military forces that are out there, right?
Or at least the kind of the kind of period military forces.
They're typically individuals that are specialized in taking super powered
beings.
And so right now we know that like super powered beings exist have existed in
this universe. Uh, so captain Britain's on the very first one they've ever seen,
but he's able to kind of get up,
get past these guys pretty easily and take out the junk heap that walked like a
man, right? So that happens pretty fast, pretty quickly.
Now these guys who exist out there for the purpose of taking out superheroes,
that's kind of an important thing. Those guys specifically are not,
but the force they will bring in for the purpose of taking down the heroes will
be, will prove to be exceedingly important.
But the other thing that happens is that once this junk heap is basically
defeated, this is kind of left and this great, big, huge, you know,
crumble heap that you end up having captain Britain,
who sort of looks around for what this stuff is right for like how it is that
this happened.
And people are talking about a kind of fluid or something like that.
And he stumbled across the sewer drain where this sort of, you know,
reddish fluid is coming out.
And when he crawls to the drain and traces it back to its energy source or to
its, to its location, he comes across a rat called auger knock, right.
He's just the rat thing, right. And this is a walking,
talking rat who lives in the sewer and is like, you know, not super intelligent,
but like level intelligence, right? So like he's basically achieved sentience.
And it's kind of a strange thing because while that's happening,
you also have something called the avant guard.
And the on guard is really kind of introduced to us a little bit mysteriously.
We don't really know much about them.
All we really know is they're led by a woman who's referred to as her Wyness,
but she starts talking about this concept of initiating something called the
push and that the rat himself is the result of the push, right.
Which is to say this chemical, that exists, that's kind of being put out there,
uh, this wreck consumed it.
And that's why it's so intelligent now what all that means will come to fruition
exceedingly soon, right?
So I'm not gonna leave you guys hanging on why all that's important,
but what does matter here is a captain Britain was in effect an unexpected
entity here, right? He wasn't really expected to be here.
And so what you end up getting is essentially the avant-garde you kind of step
in for the purpose of detaining captain Britain.
Now he ends up getting the upper hand on him,
basically kind of defeating him to a degree,
or at least that seems to be the case,
but then ultimately they get the upper hand on him.
And the way in which they do this comes in the form of a question,
the mysterious energy beam, this energy meme is shot at the rat,
which kind of devolves him back down into a base level and then a shot of
captain Britain, which devolves him back down into a monkey. Right?
And so following that, he's basically captured and taken by the avant garde.
And then in turn, we're properly introduced to Saturday now, Saturday,
and Ashley's introduced here.
And as we're informed by her is basically part of a group called the Omni Versal
development court. Now,
something that I do want to point out here is that back then in the 1980s,
when this story was written,
this was done at a time when the living tribunal was not something that was
constantly invoked nowadays in Marvel comics,
anything that really involves the multi-verse on a grand scale,
the living tribunal pops up that then it wasn't really the case.
The expectation on the publishing side was tell the story as if it's in
isolation and introduce new concepts. If you can, things that are interesting,
but don't use a living tribunal as an easy way out.
And that's why we don't really see the tribunal here. Instead,
what we get in its place is a creation by Alan Moore and Alan Davis called the
Omni Versal development court. And the way this works is that in every universe,
across the multi-verse, they all sort of progress at a particular rate.
And that at a particular point in time, certain things are supposed to happen,
right? So you have what's called the 50,000 year program,
which basically says that at some point we can call this 0.0 50,000 years.
From that point in time,
we're supposed to get a kind of evolutionary process now how this works in
tandem with like the celestial experimenting on humanity.
We're not really given a definitive explanation here.
We can largely kind of make assumptions that around 50,000 years before this
point in time,
when superheroes are supposed to have here is essentially when modern man became
what it is. And we can largely kind of tie these numbers together.
And it really kind of makes sense that about 50,000 years before the emergence
of superheroes is when the Celestials experimented on early math.
And so that's why the Omnia bristle development court seems to fall in line with
the Celestials right? That as part of the celestial grand experiment,
they travel from world to world experimenting on the early primitive versions of
its inhabitants. And then basically granting them powers on earth.
They did the exact same thing, right on earth. They showed up,
they took one third of humanity and then broke that one third into the,
into thirds itself. That one group became the Eternals.
Another group became a deviance and the third group were individuals whose
powers would manifest at some future point in time.
What seems to happen is the Omni vessel development court picks up from there.
And they basically make sure that this evolutionary push,
which is to say that the genes manifest.
So basically we get like X-Men and we get mutants and we get Avengers and
fantastic for that.
All that stuff happens about 50,000 years after the Celestials first visit
earth. And it happens across every single universe, right? And so,
because of that, on this earth, there are no superheroes.
And that's why Saturn EAN and the,
the really her forces are here is to initiate the push that it has to be
achieved by the year 2000. And that, because there are no SU superheroes here,
her assumption is that superheroes just simply never evolved, right.
For whatever reason, those genes never really activated.
And so the intention here is to initiate the push, to force those genes,
to activate, to create superheroes on earth, right.
It's just what the Omni versa development court does now, when that happens.
And when captain Britain basically kind of, uh,
his age back up to his normal self, right? When his,
when his evolution is kicked back up to where it's supposed to be,
he basically re or really evolves back into a man.
This is one part Allen Warren, Alan Davis,
giving him like new levels of super strength and speed and durability,
things like that enhancing his powers. But it's also,
it also allows him to basically kind of grabs her attorney, right, and say like,
what's going on here?
And that's when she really kind of explains everything that I just told you guys
in terms of what she does and all that kind of stuff.
But what she also ends up revealing here is that their intention is to
essentially take this substance,
this liquid that they have and put it into the water supply and the water
supply, or, you know, putting it,
there will basically allow people to consume it. And that will in turn,
start pushing them to a higher evolutionary state.
And it'll basically allow them to see the world the way that it really is.
Because one of the things that's kind of hint here is that, uh,
Jim Jasper versus kind of use his powers to distort the way the earth appears as
opposed to the way that it actually is. But the other thing it'll do,
it'll start jump-starting powers, right? People will start getting superpowers.
And so while that happens, you have essentially the,
the status crew that shows up here and the status crew is kind of a military
group that works for the government in England.
And that's kind of the superhero group that travels around and like capture
super powered beings or takes them out,
basically eliminates super-powered threats. And for the most part,
they're all taken out pretty quickly by captain Britain,
Saturday in the avant guard, those guys are defeated quite handedly,
but in the middle of it,
these various guys are essentially splashed with this evolutionary chemical by
captain Britain. And that's when I start to realize like they've been used,
right. Their minds have essentially been tricked. And so if telepathy,
which seems to be the case has been used by Jim Jasper's,
or at least some kind of reality warping ability that in turn,
it basically takes away that effect.
And they start to see the world the way it is that by virtue of their actions,
they've created grave injustices, right? Like they've oppressed, social classes,
different things like that.
And so realizing the effect that it has happen in Britain basically ends up
traveling out for the purpose of ensuring that this, uh,
this liquid is actually put into the water supply and that everything goes
according to plan now, for the most part,
it seemingly does right there that once this stuff is put into the water supply
and everything, you know, the, the push begins to happen.
The various citizens from across in London start to kind of have this awakening
where they start to realize, okay,
nothing in this world is the way that it's supposed to be, right.
If things are screwed up, you know,
that we need to focus on making things better.
This is really kind of Allen Warren Allen Davis sort of criticizing society at
the time. And just kind of being like, you know, people need to wake up,
you know, wake up sheeple, you know,
that kind of a thing and make the world a better place.
But what is going on is that while this huge celebration is happening and that
essentially this will lead to people,
developing powers that during all this time,
everybody forgot about Jasper's right. Everybody forgot about Jim Jaspers.
And so did Saturday Nene,
or she never considered him to be important in the first place,
because in her mind, she never knew that he was the cause of all this.
And so Jim Jaspers watches all this unfold. He lets them stay for this moment.
And then he initiates the Jasper's war and the Jasper's work literally just
starts twisting up the entirety of reality.
Like it really just starts warping it, twisting it, skewing it,
turning it inside out the laws of physics begin to go upside down.
So gravity starts pushing away instead of pulling in all kinds of crazy things,
start to pop off. When that happens,
nobody in the Omni Versal development court knows what's going on.
And the biggest fear is that this is a result of the push that when they did
this,
they did something wrong that they screwed something up and they totally screwed
up the world. Right. They literally broke the world. And so in response to this,
uh, you know,
you basically have the status crew that shows back up with a being called the
fury. And as they describe it,
the fury was designed and programmed for the sole purpose of killing
superheroes, right? That's its sole purpose is basically killing superheroes.
And so following that,
the fury literally kind of goes on the attack and where captain Britain launches
an attack against it. Nothing happens, right? I mean, this guy has no,
like this guy has no answer for the power of the fury.
And so Saturday and seeing what's going on Ramsey avant-garde and it's like,
let's go like unload what's going on in this world. But this place of screwed,
right?
I'm just going to get while the getting's good and we'll figure out what to do
later. And so while that happens,
the furious goes on a rampage and literally just starts annihilating everybody.
It kills Jack dock,
which is religious them kind of beginning the process of writing Jack doll out.
Uh, it goes after captain Britain.
And then of course in the middle of this whole fight,
suddenly Jim Jasper shows right in his flying teapot and rescues captain
Britain.
And this is when we start to get into the meat and potatoes of what it is that
makes mad. Jim Jasper's so powerful. And so as he's carving,
as he kind of grabs his hat to Britain and flies away, the fury stops, right?
The fury does nothing. It doesn't go after Jim Jasper's or anybody.
And so from there, Jim, Jaspers kind of starts breaking down the conversation.
Now, once Brian Brodick, once captain Britain gets in here,
he immediately knows something's off because the inside of this flying teapot is
much bigger than the flying teapot itself.
He kind of starts breaking hands down. And he says, here in this universe,
that he's in that he was a person who was a member of parliament and that he
realized, you know, at some point in time,
he had the ability to manipulate reality, right?
He had the ability to control reality on a universal scale,
but his powers are continually growing.
And so what this shows is that this version of Jasper's is still relatively new
to his abilities.
And so they more or less seemed to have just recently manifested.
And so in light of that and realizing the power that he possessed,
that the wrong move to make would have just been to distort reality that the
best move to make when it comes to taking over people is to get them to believe
you. It's one thing to conquer people.
It's another to get them to be willing to be conquered.
And that's what he was doing. Right?
What he ended up doing was passing legislation,
or at least pushing through the idea of legislation of superhuman registration,
saying like,
we need to basically get rid of all the superheroes and because of the fact that
he was able to rally various human various people to aside,
this basically led to him kind of forcing this legislation through parliament
and response to that. He in turn,
created the fury and literally just went through and sort of killing everybody,
like killing all the different superheroes.
Now there was a captain Britain in this universe and we'll actually find more
about her here in a little while, but the theory, just in a matter of,
of something like two years killed every single superhero on earth, right?
Everybody on earth. Now there's a lot that we're not being told here.
We're not being told if the fury killed,
like the fantastic four and the X-Men and the Avengers Marvel UK was largely
kind of a separate imprint.
You did see some reprints of comics from America in Marvel, UK,
which has them kind of,
that was them testing the waters and seeing if there was an interest there.
That's what made captain Britain so important.
It was the first time that Britain really got from Marvel comics,
their own character in a series of newly created stories,
as opposed to reprints of old stories. Right?
So that's why you don't really see a lot of other superhero teams here because a
lot of the emphasis was put directly on, uh,
on captain Britain because they were trying to push the idea of a British
superhero community.
But what Brian Brodick comes to the realization that one Jim Jasper's created
the fury and programmed it. And so the,
the fury will basically kill every single superhero on earth,
except for Jim Jasper's is just basically programmed not to. And that,
to the reason Jasper's did this is because he just wanted to eliminate the
competition. He just wanted to be the most powerful mutant on earth.
And the reason why everything in this reality is so weird and why you have like
the crazy gang, a lot of things reminiscent of, of like Alison Wonderland.
And then, you know,
all this kind of crazy stuff that's happening is because of the fact that Jim
Jasper's powers are expanding. And while he is able to control them,
he's experimenting, he's exceeding, he seen what he can do,
how much reality he can change. And so as time progresses,
his hold on reality becomes stronger and stronger to the point that he initiated
this Jasper's Wharf and started twisting everything up.
And so what is happening is that in the middle of this conversation,
that basically Jim Jasper's kind of created illusions of everybody that Brian
Braddock knows, like, like, uh, like Jack DAW, of course, who's dead.
All these people he encountered, like,
it's really him just screwing with the mind of, of Brian Braddock.
And so in the midst of all this Brian panicked and then just out of the, uh,
out of the teapot, he goes right out of the flying teapot. He goes,
and he ends up landing into, in a cemetery.
And then basically he's just kind of there going nuts, right. He just kind of,
he believes he's actually losing his mind. Right.
And he believes he's been abandoned by Merlin Merlin, of course,
being the person who's responsible for creating captain Britain.
And the one who sent him on this mission, uh, is kind of like,
why did you put me here? Why like, why have you just abandoned me in this place?
This is, and this is insane. Like there's no hope for me here.
And that's absolutely true, right? This universe is beyond saving at this point.
And so what you end up getting is a fury who comes out of nowhere and basically
obliterates captain Britain. And when that happened,
you kind of jump over to the main Marvel universe for a second.
And you end up seeing captain UK.
And what you find out is that this grave where captain Britain was killed,
where Brian Braddock was killed and tossed in that grave was meant for captain
UK.
The captain UK was the captain Britain from this universe that when everything
popped off and the fury ended up losing his model theory was kind of on this
mission of killing everybody that she basically abandoned the reality, right?
She, she basically got out of the earth to 38 universe and then is essentially
a refugee in the main Marvel universe that nobody knew that she was there and
that she's still experiencing PTSD and anxiety from like the whole experience
of seeing everybody that she knows that was killed. And so following that,
you go into the resurrection of Brian Bradley, you go into captain Britain,
who's basically resurrected by Merlin and his, his daughter Roma,
the ones who are responsible for creating, you know,
all this captain Britain stuff. And they're kind of,
we're kind of given a little bit of a history there. Again,
it's not overly important. They kind of just sort of,
sort of ensure that he remembers everything that happened.
And the reason why is because sending him to the earth to 38 universe,
that was a test,
it was just an experiment to see how he would fare against somebody like Jim
Jaspers.
And the reason why is because the purpose of him being sent on that mission was
not to really defeat the earth two 38, Jim Jasper's,
but to prepare him for when he faces off against magic,
Jasper's from the main Marvel universe.
Because as powerful as that version of Jim Jasper's was from earth to 38,
that guy is nothing,
absolutely nothing in comparison to the power of magic.
Jasper's from the main Marvel universe,
which is something that we'll cover in the next video with that being said,
guys, we're going to bring.
This video to an end. If.
You are new here to come as explained to make sure you guys are the sub button
to become part of the Rob Ford, the guys enjoyed this video,
make sure you drop a light and I will catch you all later.
Bruce,
[inaudible].